dustin was such
a life force and such an incredibly
brilliant comedy actor and
so it didn't feel complete for sure
but i feel
good about
the care
and the heart with which we all were
able to
um honor him and celebrate him
we have so much fun stuff to talk about
i laughed out loud so many times so many
great meta moments and callbacks to the
original series let's talk all about it
jessie's got a lot going on in season
two she's going through a divorce her
former flame slater is just down the
hall
what are you most excited
for fans to see in season two of this
reboot oh my gosh there is so much um
i'm telling you i
while filming it i just would crack up
to myself about things like that i just
knew
that while we were making certain things
that people
who we're going to watch it months later
we're just going to love so i'm so glad
that you loved it because i just felt
like each day we were sitting on some
new fun secret you know whether it be
one of the great easter eggs embedded in
a scene we had so much fun making season
two and season one was incredible too
but you know when you're establishing a
show and setting a new tone especially
because this is a reimagining and not
just a literal reboot totally um that's
why we have all these reboots of teen
shows from the 90s
get a new idea hollywood there was that
you know there's so many different
creative new
new things that obviously made it better
and made it more relevant and current
which we it needed to be able to come
back right and of course we had tracy
wigfield who is a genius and our writers
um and our new great cast so
season one really planted the seeds from
where we were able to go in season two
we see
my character jessie
just
a bit of a mess and and you know there's
it's for me it's fun to see a character
who's cut maybe down and
trying to navigate um especially a
character like jesse who usually is
really
buttoned up exactly taipei has got it
all together so when you see someone
like that just trying to get through the
day
comedy ensues
everybody knows i'm getting a divorce
fate is real you're working at the same
school as your first love and we get to
see her let loose i could not believe
that you guys went there with the
showgirls reference elizabeth it made my
week
i thought you guys were just going to
drop the line about vegas but you fully
re-channeled nomi
what are friends for
what was that like for you did you have
any apprehension were you like let's do
it first of all i love your enthusiasm
about the showgirls bit in in episode
six we definitely had a lot of fun we
had an incredible female director katie
locke o'brien our writer yamara taylor
and and of course tracy
um
we
tracy and yamara approached me pretty
early on when they were breaking the
season before we even went to film the
show
and they said to me look we have this
idea
and tracy said
i don't know how you feel about it all
but would you be game to explore this i
said to her well as you're getting to
know me you have to know that i have a
great sense of humor as long as we're
not mocking it but actually
that it
is truly funny and fun and smart the way
i know
you know i said to tracy the way i know
you know how to do things um why don't
you guys show me some pages first
and so then they
they showed me the first few pages of it
and i just said i'm in i'm all in
that that we've got to do this
so i i knew i was going to be in a good
you know i had the team and the right
support and the rate the right creative
angle on it for sure and getting to have
lark join you guys this season it was
just like my fan girl heart was freaking
out i need a hot sunday reunion in
season
[Music]
really having lark on set was incredible
it's it's like having an old best friend
that you know you all went off let's say
to different colleges and had a
different path and then you come back
together and there's that ease and
comfort and reminiscing a show that is
filled with so many amazing easter eggs
and call backs and throwbacks for an
original fan like me it's so rewarding i
need to ask about the brief line between
you and slater saying we don't have the
budget for a stacey carrozzi flashback
oh my god so good but of course now i
need to see leah remini in season i
agree what are the chances have you
talked to her
i look like a firecracker don't i
no
but you know you could pass for an
extremely sexy harlem globetrotter i
have talked to her um early on actually
before season one we we chatted a bit
and i said oh my god it would be a dream
to have you back we did dancing with the
stars together so we've kind of kept in
touch through the years that line and
the way mario delivers it is hysterical
so good i mean it's
it's genius i'm so glad that you you
caught that one
um who knows you never know right
because
who knows if we're at the beach club
again who knows where this can all go
there's so many incredible
places um
you know that we all traveled to outside
of bayside so
it will i mean if we get to do season
three which would be such a gift and i
hope people want that because we would
love to do it for you um
you just never know who can come
visiting
we did of course lose one member of our
save by the bell family this year dustin
diamond is no longer with us but the
tribute that your saved by the bell
series does in the season 2 premiere is
so heartwarming and so touching how do
you think fans are going to react to it
and what was it like for you guys
filming that
well first of all i'm so glad that that
was your response to it that's what our
intention was and um
definitely heartbreaking
and you know in that first episode is
kind of
the we don't all say it to each other
but we all
say
are you gonna go into the max later
and you know people may not know what
that is at first but that that plants
the seeds of what you know what we come
together in the end of that episode for
and
no it was very moving we
were all sitting there in that same
booth
in a place you know obviously different
set different time different era
but it was a meaningful
huge powerful moment for all of us when
we were together on that show so to come
back together and be missing a piece
you know such a huge huge piece dustin
was such
a life force and such an incredibly
brilliant
comedy actor and so it didn't feel
complete for sure um but i feel
good about
the care
and the heart
with which we all were able to
[Music]
um honor him and celebrate him
you